(audience applauds)
- Oh my God,
have y'all met before?
- Man, we go back like bad credit, man.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
That's the little homester right there.
- Okay, I was gonna
say, did you just meet?
(all laughing)
I was like,
are you being sarcastic for a minute?
I was like, okay.
So your show is set in North Carolina?
My family actually is from
North Carolina.
- Okay.
- You also grew up there too, right?
- I did.
- Yeah, where did you grow up?
In like Greensboro, is
that right, or between-
- Raleigh-Durham?
Rocky Mountain?
- (laughing) No.
- Charlotte?
(all laughing)
- Never heard of it.
- He said Charlotte.
- Yeah,
- Charlotte.
- I never heard of it, I promise.
Kernersville, in between
Winston and Greensboro.
- I know both those places.
- Yep.
- I did a year of time in Winston-Salem.
- Okay, it's just-
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] What?
Wait, wait.
So my family's not far from there.
It's a beautiful place to grow up.
Did you love growing up there?
Like was it cool?
- I loved
- Are like the
- growing up there.
- camper girl?
Do you like outdoor stuff?
- I mean, we were outdoors all the time.
I'm like one of seven kids, so.
- [Kelly] One of seven?
- [Madison] The baby of seven,
yeah.
- Oh my gosh, your mama.
- [Madison] Steep, who
you talking- (chuckles)
- That's a lot of children.
- (laughing) Yeah, it's a lot.
So yeah,
- That's kinda magical though,
- we were always outside.
- Were you close in age?
- Not really.
- Oh, okay.
- I mean, I'm the baby
and then the oldest,
there's a 20 year age
gap in between us two.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Do you miss anything about being there?
- Oh, I miss like just growing up
with my siblings and just living a very
simple life.
- Simple, yeah.
- And we spent so much time outside and-
- That's important.
- Building forts and-
- Yeah.
- That had to be a very large fort.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, for all of you to fit.
- That must- (chuckles)
- Yeah, or-
- It's called a castle.
- Only a certain amount of people allowed.
(all laughing)
- Yeah.
So do you, did you like acting
like when you were really little?
Did you always think you
were gonna be an actor?
- Uh, so like I said, I'm
the youngest of seven kids.
- Yeah.
- So, I did a little bit
of acting growing up.
- Yeah.
I think that's called lying.
(all laughing)
- Depends who you ask, you know.
- I heard that you were into singing.
- I was into singing.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Why aren't you still singing?
- I don't know, I feel like I just kinda
lost a certain confidence getting older
and found comfort in doing something else
and
- Okay.
- when I first started acting,
I fell in love immediately
and just kind of prioritized
that to be my career
and singing's kind of my hobby, you know?
- Yeah it's a great hobby,
it's therapeutic.
- Yeah, it is therapeutic.
- Have you ever heard of Michael McDonald?
(all laughing)
- Did you know he was white?
- Did you know he's white?
(all laughing)
- What?
- That inspires anybody.
(laughter intensifies)
- So your show, Outer Banks,
just got renewed,
so this is incredible.
- It did.
So, for people that
- [Anthony] Third season.
haven't watched it yet
(audience cheers)
and they haven't binged
yet, who do you play
and what's it about?
- I play Kiara.
It's about a group of friends
going on a treasure hunt basically.
- [Kelly] Which I love.
- Me too.
- Yeah, that's, fun.
- It's very Goonies-esque.
It's a fun-
- You just-
- I literally just said-
- You know what, we've come full circle.
- Yeah, I love it, adventure.
- To tie up the circle.
(Anthony Mackie laughing)
- Yeah, yes, you're welcome.
We're weird in this interview.
(audience laughs)
I literally, when I was
playing, I was like,
it's kinda like Goonies, right?
Like you're like on a-
yeah, I love that.
- Yeah, yeah.
So is there anything else involved?
Is it just like you're adventurous
or is there romance or-
- There's a lot of romance.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- A lot of drama, of course.
- You know.
- A lot of drama in your twenties.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Boy, I would never repeat them.
- Right, if it was a forties old Goonies,
we'd be like, look-
(Kelly chuckles)
- It's either-
- Where the treasure at bro,
(Kelly and Madison laughs)
- come on man.
(overlapping speech)
- You just like buy a metal
detector and if you win,
you win.
- I gotta take this nap,
get this nap in, then we can
go look for this treasure.
(Kelly, Anthony and Madison laugh)
- So did you, I don't know if you knew
like how it was gonna blow up.
This is a very popular series, right?
So, do you get recognized everywhere now?
- Yeah, pretty much everywhere
I'm going.
- Is that,
do you like it or hate it?
- We spent two years in COVID,
in quarantine and that was like
our show came out in 2020.
I do like meeting the fans,
like I do like when people come up to me
because I haven't seen them for two years.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So-
- Another reason why
we're here, thank you.
(audience cheers)
Thank you for our jobs!